the Joe Rogan experience how many all
told of these crazy journeys have you
been on whoa
over the past decade now so the three
big ones of course the Mongolia
Madagascar and the biggest one the most
ambitious was was Mission Yangtze I
wanted to see a photo of the the Yangtze
River you were talking about yeah I
think on the insta highlights you've got
2019 it starts with but you can see it
goes right from west goes down south
kills back up and ends in is Shanghai so
there's these three big giant ones but
then there's some other ones yes so
there's the Vietnam Cambodia cycle has
trekking Himalayas which was a scary one
so we wanted to check the Himalayas they
said that we needed to buy a permit but
we didn't believe that we did he was
like a wave to get money out of it it
was we were shoestring budget travelers
and we were like now we can do this
let's go he got it got worse he got to a
point where it was like you know you
can't go the Pakistan Army roamed the
border of Indian Himalayas and Pakistani
Malaya's so you'd go on your knees if
you come across the Pakistan Army put
yeah you know your thumbs behind your
ears and say Allah who Rigby repeatedly
and that like sort of means Allah have
mercy on me so it's at that point we
were like should we obey all of that
they taught you how to beg for mercy if
we came across the the military it's
that much of an issue I thought that was
his way of trying to scare us to get us
to pay for a permit that we didn't need
how much was a permit I have no idea I
should know if it was reasonable I would
say probably we yeah we we were such it
was crazy that's so easy you got like
little hammock hammock shops in Vietnam
as we were cycling sometimes we sleep in
the hammock shop it would cost you about
20 cents for the night a hammock sharp
hammock so you sense the hammocks yeah
that's a good deal
great that Hey yeah good sleep it's not
hotel you don't you toilets don't have
any of that but so MX if you're in a
real woody area that seems like not a
bad option yeah yeah did you get one no
we're only stuck to the hammock shots
because we're on a bicycle so we were on
roads so that wasn't necessarily how
much of the hammock wire Oh
you can get superlight ones now you
probably get one four kilogram maybe
even yeah around a kilogram I'd say
maybe even lighter yeah that would be a
great way if as long as there's enough
trees what that C way he does it on yeah
that's uh you take it away off the
ground with all the creepy crawlies yeah
yeah for sure
does he get stung by any creepy cries I
did spiders spiders I was so what when
you're hacking through the jungle you've
got the jungle canopy and the leeches
believe it or not oh [ __ ] man how do you
know that's okay so then worried I
didn't feel it you know when it happened
because as you hack hacking through the
jungle you've got loads of bamboo shorts
and they all raised a shop messing
around
you've got leeches at the night time you
take your top off and you've got apply
six seven leeches off your body freak
them out then you've got this bite which
infected there's a lot of aloe vera
plants around that area though so you
can just rip off the aloe vera your hell
that's really in fact it looks so lit up
if you click on that photo with me
standing on the rock or the dragon do
you notice anything weird about that
image Gertrude was Gertrude Gertrude the
chicken so in order to summit the
highest mountain in Madagascar the
herbarium show you is it's tradition you
must take yourself a white cockerel
protect it keep it alive and it protects
you from the bad spirits and witches of
the rainforest the locals say so I'm all
about respect in the local culture of
course you have to bring a chicken how
long are you carrying this chicken
around how many two and a half weeks two
weeks [ __ ] yes that's all in my bag shat
all over my tent it was sleep on Sol my
tent wouldn't leave me became
domesticate like a little dog okay
everybody just followed me around
everywhere oh my god showing off week
chirping in my ear praying for a little
bit of rain cuz when it started raining
he took himself inside the bag you
wouldn't make noises poking right in 14
hours you've got this chirping chicken
on your shoulder no is he just perched
on your shoulder or do you have easier
compartment on the on the back so you
haven't strapped in
we have occasional words if din yeh
can't really get away
why in the [ __ ] is your arm going
through the jungle that's why we Lam out
a lot of the time he should be running
trailing behind us was great and you got
to leave him on top of that mountain so
that was a swarm day is so ridiculous
she's just hanging around yeah couple of
days yeah video this chicken hanging
around with you do i I don't like I do
by gonna fuss on my Instagram that is
hilarious
but yeah girl showing your boy were just
chilling with a chicken here we go by
the way that guy has like woman's dress
shoes from the shoes man sometimes he'd
walk barefoot and it was only one I said
you've literally missed a scorpion by a
foot those sandals on so yeah like a
five year old girl yeah they all right
yeah yes the nails Bushman look you
don't give a [ __ ] like yeah he's just
there to hike that is a crazy [ __ ]
chicken man that whole thing that's so
strange the end of it did you eat it no
so we have to set him free on top of
that we can't even take him back down so
I was hoping you'd follow us down you
know built a bit of a bond with a
flaming chicken you know but he then we
couldn't eat them either because they
said that the bus appears then goes it
seems like a bad idea if you eat them
yeah no barbecue sauce either yeah
unless you were starving right what
would you do if you're stuck in you're
starving we would have no choice which
we can then we have no choice and the
first but you would be worried about the
spirits exactly and if we took him down
to a community that community would
parent flip on us you know we'd be
introduced into which is under bad
spirits witches
yeah they believe in witches chickens
carry witches with them chicken no which
is a scared of white chickens so that's
why we needed Gertrude that is hilarious
believe in witches which is awesome they
got some mad stories as well so max my
guide he said so my take on it is we
were we were in the middle of this
community deep in the jungle high up in
the mountains in the middle of
Madagascar you know the fourth largest
island in the world and we came across a
community and they allowed us to stay in
their little wooden shack sort of hot
and I woke up about two o'clock in the
morning let's say don't know what time
two o'clock in the morning and it's max
coming in he should have been sleeping
right next to his
smacks my photographer me and lever the
chicken next to max Gertrude and he came
in with this machete and I say you're
right it's like yeah yeah good and his
story is that me lever and Suzanne were
all convulsing in our sleep or shaking
and then he looks up to the door and
they hit the silhouette of this lady was
stood on the outside from the moon stood
in the outside of the door peering in
and he shouted like I you know get away
in Malagasy anyway was freaked out we
were awfully still cursed I have no I
don't remember any of this I was
thinking now come on you gotta be lying
it takes the machete and then he chases
this witch like figure into the jungle
runs about 100 meters when she enters
the jungle bloom she disappears and then
when he walks back to the to the hut he
said you'd stop convulsing you woke up
ash and asked if I was all right and I
was like no and I was like the only one
that I felt I was the only sane one
there saying come on that's gonna be a
load of rubbish
Shirley like will use sleepwalking
suffered with a night Sara Mariel and he
said no and the only reason that I
wasn't convulsing is Gertrude was
sleeping next to me whoa Susanna our
photographer from Belgium which is
absolutely breaking herself then you
know what's going on we're always slides
have we got a Blair Witch Project yeah
so you're stuck in this tent now with
people that are crazy
yeah the old witches are like peering
into there like you gotta be weirded out
and they're all telling me their
individual stories at their which
experiences as well
[Applause]